Daniel is one of the most extraordinary
prophets in the Old Testament exiled to
Babylon by the Tyrant King
Nebuchadnezzar God bestowed upon Daniel
wisdom and granted him dreams and
apocalyptic visions of things to come in
this video we are going to examine some
of Daniel's astonishing prophecies that
all point to the coming of the Prophet
Muhammad
upon whom be
peace Daniel chapter 2 informs us about
a dream that greatly Disturbed the
Babylonian King
nebukadnezar your majesty looked and
there before you stood an enormous
dazzling statue the head of the statue
was made of pure gold its chest and arms
of silver its belly and thighs of bronze
its legs of iron its feet partly of iron
and partly of baked clay he here we are
informed that the Babylonian King
Nebuchadnezzar dreamt of a dazzling
statue comprised of the materials of
gold silver bronze iron and Clay Daniel
interpreted the dream as follows your
majesty you are that head of gold after
you another kingdom will arise inferior
to yours next a third Kingdom one of
bronze will rule the whole earth finally
there will be a fourth kingd Kingdom
strong as iron as iron breaks things to
Pieces so it will crush and break all
the others just as the feet and Toes
were partly of baked clay and partly of
iron so this will be a divided Kingdom
this Kingdom will be partly strong and
partly brittle according to Daniel the
different sections of the statue
represented four successive kingdoms who
would rule on Earth Daniel explicitly
tells us that the first of these
kingdoms represented by the statues head
of gold is Babylon the kingdom which was
in power during his day the identities
of the second and third kingdoms are
revealed in a later Vision in Daniel
chapter
8 in the third year of King belshazzar's
Reign I Daniel had a vision there before
me was a Ram with two horns no animal
could stand against it suddenly a goat
with a prominent horn came toward the
two horns RAM and charged at it in Great
rage the ram was powerless to stand
against it the goat became very great
but at the height of its power the large
horn was broken off and in its place
four prominent horns grew up the
prophecy goes on to inform us that the
Ram with two horns symbolizes a combined
Kingdom consisting of midor Persians the
two horned Ram that you saw represents
the kings of media and Persia the Two
horned Ram is an excellent symbol as the
two horns represent the two powers of
the mes and Persians who historically
United under Cyrus the Great so where in
the sequence of Kingdoms does the Mido
Persian Empire fit the prophets Isaiah
and Jeremiah answer this question for us
because they informed us that Babylon
would be defeated by the mes see I will
stir up against them the mes Babylon the
jewel of Kingdoms will be overthrown by
God the Lord has stirred up the kings of
the mes because his purpose is to
destroy
Babylon historically King Bazar who we
have been told was in power at the time
of Daniel's vision of the two-horned ram
was the last Babylonian ruler in the
year 539 BCE he was defeated by Cyrus
the Great who commanded the midor
Persian Empire thus we can conclude that
the midor Persian Empire is the second
Kingdom in Nebuchadnezzar's dream the
kingdom that is depicted as the statue
silver chest and arms and is said to
defeat Babylon what about the symbol of
the goat as the animal that will defeat
the two-horned Ram with the goat's
prominent horn then splitting into four
smaller horns Daniel chapter 8 informs
us that the goat represents the Greeks
the shaggi goat is the king of Greece
and the large lar horn between its eyes
is the first king the four horns that
replace the one that was broken off
represent four kingdoms that will emerge
from his Nation but will not have the
same power historically Alexander the
Great was King of the ancient Greek
Kingdom of Macedon he overthrew the Mido
Persians and created a vast Empire the
likes of which the world had never seen
he died suddenly in the year 323 BC with
his Empire descending into chaos
eventually splitting up into four stable
but weaker power blocks we can see that
Alexander the Great perfectly fits
Daniel's vision of the goat with a
prominent horn that splits into four
horns so far it has been demonstrated
how the golden head represents Babylon
the chest and arms of silver represents
the Mido Persians and that the belly and
thighs of bronze represents the
macedonians
we will now switch Focus back to
nebuchad nazar's dream in Daniel chapter
2 what about the remaining portion of
the statue which is said to have legs of
iron with feet partly of iron and partly
of baked clay Daniel interpreted this
fourth Kingdom to be strong as iron as
iron breaks things to Pieces so it will
crush and break all the others we can
see that the fourth kingdom is described
as being far stronger than those
kingdoms which come before it
historically the emergence of the Roman
Empire perfectly matches this
description the Romans annihilated the
Macedonian Empire dissolving their
territory into Roman provinces the Roman
Empire went from strength to strength
eventually ruling over vast parts of the
world more than any other Empire before
it Daniel also mentioned that this
fourth Kingdom will be a divided Kingdom
partly strong and partly brittle again
this perfectly describes the Roman
Empire by the end of the 4th Century CE
it had split into two with the western
part ruling from Rena and the eastern
part ruling from Constantinople although
it was weakened both halves of the Roman
Empire continued to be among the
strongest powers in the world in summary
we have now identified all four kingdoms
symbolized by the statue in
Nebuchadnezzar's dream Babylon the midor
Persian Empire the Macedonian Empire and
the Roman Empire this brings us onto the
final part of Nebuchadnezzar's dream
while you were watching a rock was cut
out but not by human hands it struck the
statue then the iron the clay the bronze
the silver and the gold were all broken
to Pieces but the rock that struck the
statue became a huge mountain and filled
the whole earth Dan Daniel interprets
this portion of the dream as follows in
the time of those kings the god of
heaven will set up a kingdom that will
never be destroyed it will crush all
those kingdoms but it will itself endure
forever we can see that The Rock in
Nebuchadnezzar's dream is interpreted by
Daniel to be a fifth Kingdom note the
key characteristics of this coming
Kingdom first it is said that God of
heaven will set it up second it will
will become a huge mountain that fills
the whole earth third the kingdoms which
preceded it will be crushed historically
it is only Islam which fulfills all
these characteristics of the rock the
7th Century CE saw the emergence of
Islam as a force to be reckoned with in
the words of Daniel Islam crushed and
brought to an end the world Empires at
the time including the mighty Romans and
Persians the early Muslims defeated them
in war capturing many of their lands
which remain under Muslim rule to this
day the Islamic empire spread rapidly
and went on to become one of the largest
that the world had ever seen unlike the
idolatrous empires that came before it
Prophet Muhammad and his companions were
Godly in character preaching monotheism
and implementing the law of God as
divinely revealed in the Quran note how
Daniel relates the kingdoms to one
another he spoke of five consecutive
kingdoms which would emerge one after
the other beginning with Babylon and
ending with God's Kingdom in all of
history there is no series of events
which fits Daniel's sequence other than
the emergence of the kingdoms of Babylon
the midor Persians Macedonia Rome and
Islam critics May cite the fact that
jewi commentators have traditionally
Associated Islam not with God's kingdom
but rather the fourth evil Kingdom one
of the ways they do this is by merging
Rome into the third Kingdom to create a
combined Macedonian Roman Empire however
such interpretations are highly
problematic because there is nothing in
the prophecy which indicates that the
third kingdom is a joint Empire it's
important to note that not a sing single
Jewish commentator prior to the Advent
of Islam interpreted the fourth Kingdom
to be the Rise of an ishmaelite Empire
professor John J Collins a leading
expert on Daniel acknowledges that
rabbis distorted its interpretation
after the rise of Islam the prevailing
interpretation identified the kingdoms
as Babylon media Persia Greece and Rome
eventually the sequence was adapted to
take account of the new developments
specifically the rise of Islam it's
apparent that Jewish commentators only
started to link the fourth evil Kingdom
to Ishmael after the Advent of Islam and
its subsequent establishment as a world
power as they knew the implication was
that Islam is the foretold kingdom of
God this is made clear in Jewish
writings just prior to the Advent of
Islam where fifth Century rabbis who
were living under the oppressive Roman
Empire were anticipating the imminent
arrival of a salvific figure who would
defeat the fourth Kingdom Rome and Usher
in the Messianic age rabbis wrote in the
Babylonian talmud those Empires
subjugated the Jewish people with regard
to Rome and Persia their kingship
extends until the coming of the
Messiah a final Point worth mentioning
is that the early Muslims were fully
aware of such prophecies in Daniel for
example a leading expert on Jewish
scriptures and also a direct student of
famous companions such as IBN Abbas said
the following nebukadnezar saw a dream
that there will be a statue with a head
of gold Daniel said that you are the
head of the statue that you saw as for
the stone that will come down that will
fill the heavens and the Earth earth
that is about the prophet who will come
at the end of
times the next prophecy we are going to
examine can be found in Daniel chapter 7
which informs us that Daniel experienced
a terrifying dream of four beasts the
first was like a lion and it had the
wings of an eagle then a second beast
which looked like a bear it was raised
up on one of its sides and it had three
ribs in its mouth then another Beast one
that looked like a leopard it had four
wings like a bird and four heads after
that a fourth Beast terrifying and
frightening and very powerful it had
large iron teeth it was different from
all the former beasts and it had 10
horns Daniel interpreted the four beasts
to represent the emergence of Four Kings
the four Great beasts are four kings
that will rise from the the Earth as
shall now be seen these four beasts
symbolize the same four kingdoms
depicted in nead nazar's dream about the
Statue which we covered previously here
Daniel described the first Beast as a
lion with the wings of an eagle Prophet
Jeremiah identified this Kingdom when he
forewarned of Jerusalem's impending
destruction a lion has come out of his
lair a destroyer of Nations has s set
out his horses are swifter than Eagles
woe to us we are ruined note Jeremiah's
prophecy which characterized Jerusalem's
Destroyer as a ferocious lion swifter
than an eagle which mirrors Daniel's
symbolism of the first Beast
historically this points to Babylon as
shortly after Jeremiah's prophecy King
Nebuchadnezzar laid waste to Jerusalem
and took the Israelites to Babylon in
captivity with regard to the second
beast Daniel described it as a bear
raised up on one of its sides this
mirrors the imagery of the Ram with one
horn longer than the other that we
discussed earlier recall that Daniel
specifically Associated the two horned
Ram with the midor Persians Daniel's
mention of the three ribs in the Bear's
mouth also relates to the midor Persians
from a historical perspective who at the
height of their power had an Empire
which spanned three continents Asia
Africa and Europe regarding the third
Beast Daniel described it as a leopard
with four heads and four wings this
description mirrors the imagery of the
goat that we discussed earlier recall
that Daniel specifically Associated the
goat with the Greeks like the goat's
prominent horn that Daniel mentioned
would split into four smaller horns The
Mention Of The leopard's four heads and
four wings also historically mirrors the
Macedonian Empire which we've seen split
into four smaller power blocks after the
death of Alexander the Great we now come
to the fourth and final Beast which
Daniel described as having iron teeth
and 10 horns this description mirrors
the imagery of the fourth Kingdom from
Nebuchadnezzar's dream with the iron
teeth matching the statue's iron legs
and the 10 horns matching the statues 10
toes all of these parallels between the
fourth Beast and the fourth Kingdom
indicate that both are talking about the
same entity which we previously
concluded was the Roman Empire rabbis
also understood this fourth Beast to
represent the Roman Empire for example
they wrote in the Babylonian talmud as
it is written in the Book of Daniel with
regard to the fourth Empire this Empire
that will devour the Earth is the wicked
Roman Empire in summary we can see that
the four kingdoms symbolized as beasts
in Daniel's dream are the same four
Kingdoms in Nebuchadnezzar's dream about
the Statue why does the Book of Daniel
repeat the same prophecy using two
different dreams with different
symbolism in each their symbolism
differs because of the recipients of the
dreams Nebuchadnezzar visualized the
kingdoms as a dazzling statue made of
precious metals this could be a
reflection of his disbelief as a pagan
King by contrast Daniel visualized the
kingdoms as terrifying beasts as a
prophet he understood the true vicious
and ugly reality of the kingdoms because
of his god-given spiritual Insight
coming back to Daniel's dream he goes on
to describe the fourth Beast Rome in
more detail the 10 horns are 10 Kings
who will come from this Kingdom after
them another king will arise he will
subdue three kings he will speak against
the most high and oppress his holy
people and change the set times and the
laws the holy people will be delivered
into his hands for a time times and half
a time but the court will sit and his
power will be taken away and completely
destroyed forever then the power of all
the kingdoms under heaven will be handed
over to the the holy people of the most
high as we are going to see there is
only one Roman ruler in history who
fulfilled all of these details
Constantine the Great at the end of the
3rd Century CE the Roman Empire had a
form of government where power was
divided among four individuals during
this time Constantine was a military
commander in Rome's Armed Forces who
served under his father emperor Emperor
constantius I first Constantine Rose to
power upon the death of his father soon
after his Ascension a series of Civil
Wars broke Out Among the four rulers
with Constantine emerging triumphant
over his three Rivals and ending up as
the sole ruler of the Roman Empire in
the year 324 CE this is a fulfillment of
Daniel's prophecy that the prominent
King will defeat three other kings
Constantine inherited a Roman Empire
which was religiously divided with
Christians holding varying theological
beliefs about the nature of Jesus in the
year 325 CE Constantine convened the
Council of NAIA in the hope that he
could unite Christians by coming up with
a universally acceptable definition of
the nature of Jesus according to
historians it was Constantine himself
who proposed the most controversial
clause in the naan Creed known as homo
Usos that is the concept that Jesus
shares the same substance as God the
father from a Jewish perspective
Constantine's Council of NAA was an act
of blasphemy as it attributed Supreme
Divinity to a human being so Constantine
when viewed through the monotheistic
lens of the Old Testament can absolutely
be described as a fulfillment of
Daniel's prophecy that the prominent
King will speak against God Constantine
was not just a catalyst for theological
changes he was also responsible for
changes to ritualistic aspects of
religion for example he officially
established a Sunday Sabbath in Roman
law which stands in opposition to the
Saturday Sabbath of the Old Testament
hence Constantine is also a fulfillment
of Daniel's prophecy that the prominent
King will change the set times and laws
of God the Roman Empire's fortunes
radically changed in the 7th Century
with the Advent of Islam the early
Muslims militarily defeated the Roman
Empire capturing many of their lands
significantly Constantine's Imperial
Palace which was built in the capital
city of Constantinople a Greek word
meaning the city of Constantine was also
captured Ed by the Muslims for nearly a
millennium Constantinople was the Jewel
of the Roman empire being the largest
and wealthiest city in Europe the city
fell to the Muslim Ottoman Empire and
remains under Muslim control to the
present day now being known as Istanbul
hence the Advent of Islam is a perfect
fulfillment of Daniel's prophecy that
the prominent king's court and power
will be taken away Daniel even go goes
on to provide us with an exact timeline
as to when God's kingdom would emerge
Daniel for told that God's people will
be oppressed by The prominent king for a
duration of time described as a time
times and half a time with regards to
the mention of times how should this be
interpreted the word used in the
prophecy for times is the Aramaic plural
form ananin which generally means two or
more units of time the majority of
interpreters however understand it in
the Dual sense I.E two units of time a
Bible commentary on this prophecy
informs us the plural word times can
only designate the simple plural I.E two
times used in the Dual
sense now Daniel does not define how
long a unit of time is is however if we
classify one unit of time to be a
century and if we go with the majority
interpretation of times to be two units
of time then Daniel gives us a
calculation of 350 years as follows one
century plus two centuries plus half a
century remarkably this timeline also
points to the rise of Islam it just so
happens that 350 years is the exact span
of time from the birth of Constantine in
the year 272 CE to the year of the Hijra
in 622 CE the Hijra is a Monumental
Milestone marking the start of the
Islamic calendar and the year in which
prophet Muhammad upon whom be peace fled
meccan persecution and set up the first
Muslim state in the city of Medina we
can see that there the Advent of Islam
perfectly fulfills Daniel's timeline for
when God's kingdom would emerge such
calculations are standard methods
employed by rabbis when interpreting
scripture for example Rabbi Ben
abrahamson used similar calculations
based on other prophecies in Daniel and
he also arrived at the year 622 CE which
is when he says the true warrior Messiah
was for told to emerge in a Arabia
Daniel had prophecied that 490 years had
passed until this year 622 CE now would
come the true warrior Messiah although
rare even in Arabia parents hoping that
their child might be this Messiah might
name him after Daniel ish hamud do man
of delights
Muhammad in summary the prophecy of the
four beasts in Daniel chapter 7 has been
analyzed in great detail we have seen
that the four beasts represent the same
four kingdoms from Nebuchadnezzar's
dream about the statue in Daniel chapter
2 we have also seen that the kingdom of
God which is said to save holy people
from the oppression of the fourth Beast
is the same Kingdom symbolized as the
Divine Rock which was foretold to smash
the statue to pieces in Daniel chapter 2
upon analyzing Daniel's sequence of
these kingdoms and correlating them with
real world events we must conclude that
in all of history these prophecies can
refer to none other than the Advent of
Muhammad's prophethood and the rise of
Islam as a world power now the biggest
objection that a Christian will raise is
that Daniel is not prophesying about
Muhammad but rather Jesus Christ in
response there are serious issues with
Jesus as the Fulfillment of Daniel's
prophecies firstly the New Testament
teaches that Jesus was humiliated
tortured and executed by the fourth
Beast Rome which completely contradicts
the prophecies in Daniel 2 and 7 which
we have seen describe the emergence of a
Messianic figure who will be powerful
and have dominion on Earth symbolized as
the Divine Rock who will smash the other
kingdoms and save God's holy people from
from the oppression of the fourth Beast
Rome secondly recall that Daniel
foretold that the coming Messianic
figure will emerge after Constantine and
Usher in God's Kingdom on Earth Jesus
was born in the first century CE which
is several centuries before Constantine
so Jesus violates the chronology set out
in Daniel the renowned Christian
biblical eschatologist Joel Richardson
fully acknowledges the historical
problem that Islam pauses to Christians
when interpreting Daniel's prophecies
but you have the the historical problem
of Islam several hundred years after
Jesus Islam arose and it actually better
fulfills the biblical criteria than the
first coming of Jesus because Islam
conquered Babylon Meo Persia Greece and
it was the entity responsible for the
final collapse of Rome we can see that
the only way Christians can Sho horn
Jesus into Daniel's prophecies is By
ignoring the facts of History it is
clear that when we let Daniel speak for
itself and fact it in history as it
actually unfolded the only conclusion
one can reach is that Islam is the
Fulfillment of Daniel's foretold kingdom
of God here on
Earth for more information on biblical
prophecies about the coming of of
Muhammad upon whom be peace please
download your free copy of the book
Abraham fulfilled at the link below